[Music]
in setup news submitted by x marks the
spot
a man's Bulldog was euthanized after
biting off its owner's testicles oh
that's the specific put peanut butter on
them duh
yep oh really God he was going for it
you tonight right
and the owner sign for him to get you
tonight because the testicles came
completely off like real ominous boom
that's what you get [ __ ] that
makes me so he was he trying to be funny
or does he was he trying to come that's
true was he trying to be funny do we try
to get his balls licked with you know
fraternity he was alone with he was
manic calm I think he's trying to calm
because if he's trying to be funny they
wouldn't therapy other people around
doesn't he know that if you like get
your balls your balls don't come your
dick comes well he's probably whacking
off while he's getting yeah he's getting
support from his dog I see the 22 year
old man what a sick [ __ ] in Scotland
haha you don't have any balls until you
spread peanut butter or another food
spread on his private areas and awesome
it's fine Nutella so much blood yeah so
he was found unconscious well the
officers too is like come on man we
trying to eat a dog lick your balls
absolutely not like no way he was in a
coma for days oh my god because he's a
[ __ ] dude himself exactly they
probably had it probably had to be the
first time because yeah cuz he's been it
if yeah maybe yeah [ __ ] you I'm done
like the dog got aggressive about eating
in because maybe the guy was competing
with him for the food he was like who's
gonna and then the dogs like no no this
is my food cuz some dogs get really
aggressive when it comes to you look
he might have been I'm just I'm trying
to figure it out if like don't take my
food away from me oh maybe he wanted to
make out with the dog - so he was going
like that putting the peanut butter on
his mouth oh that way the dog would be
attracted to both places
dude just for some reason no it's the
reason why this is funny - Jo and and us
is because it's like that same story
where the guy got [ __ ] by a horse yeah
and he died because he got [ __ ] so
hard by the horse yeah like that [ __ ]
makes me laugh because he was rich it
was what he wanted that's what he was
doing it's like a horse's dick like the
size of my arm yep yeah it's pretty big
so what would you put it's flaccid even
and they're powerful animals like what
the [ __ ] was he thinking the outcome was
gonna be right yeah dude when he got out
of the coma at some Hugh Syme he
consented and signed documents to have
the dog put down [ __ ] duh [ __ ] what he
was the Freak support biggie that's the
name of the dog or the Old English
bulldog did you put him down like not
the dog but the guy that got his balls
but no I think he got what he deserved
yeah I think I think it's justice balls
ripped out by an Old English bulldog
those things are ugly as [ __ ]
keep his dick yeah I mean uh can you
there are only talking about testicles
here oh good for the guy at least that's
good he should be neutered breed that's
actually really good for everything
can you imagine what he's gonna breed
guy got neutered by his own dogs yeah oh
that's good can you use Newton on
youtube I guess we'll find out I know
Geoff even this one boob we gotta be so
[ __ ] creative these days with a title
I love it it's [ __ ] up man
every like literally half my video tip
videos didn't make any sense for it
it'll be like [ __ ] your face depends
like Devon times I'm like I'm not gonna
win this battle
yeah a lot of our old videos got
demonetised because of the title but
some of it is it's pretty it's it's hard
I wish they put like on his record like
he can no longer purchase any pets and
all the other [ __ ] he's gonna do with
the newly registered sex-offender before
pet yeah this guy could do some [ __ ]
with the cockatoo that we wouldn't even
think of that's true right
picking seeds out of his [ __ ] I had a
cockatoo
and then he would head brace at the time
and he would eat food out of my braces
you sicko
why are you trying to make out with him
he would give kisses food out of your
yeah so you know all your braces are
shiny
cuz it's metal so whenever I would talk
you would always try to come in so I'm
like oh is you want like a kiss and I'm
like let's see what happens and I did
this and use it it's picking at it do
you all watch my cat eat my other cat's
[ __ ] and then kiss my wife [ __ ] yo
[ __ ] is like that and it's absolutely
disgusting there's nothing you do about
it I don't even tell her about mg's like
she doesn't care
no she loves this [ __ ] cat so
annoying I'm jealous
I think so just like guy dogs are so
[ __ ] nasty just [ __ ] licking their
dick and balls all day and just like
little girls yeah what you don't see it
but they're like they give themselves
they clean themselves yeah they put
their leg over their head like this and
they're like going in on their [ __ ]
get to see my dog do that they do it all
day I have yet to see it mice they groom
each other - they [ __ ] eat each
other's ass see that they eat their own
poop yeah that's crazy [ __ ] [ __ ]
weird-looking now maybe I just don't
want to see that [ __ ] actually
completely ignored like not my dog yeah
but the girls do it to look at nasty
[ __ ] bleed dude I do not think I'll
never forget my grandpa we're all at the
ranch where they had like a [ __ ]
ranch and my grandpa's dog rusty that
was like his son you know I was like his
little boy you know I mean and one day
rusty and his brother dusty was just
holding like a [ __ ] beer out of me
and and then and then out of nowhere
rusty starts getting butt-fucked by
dusty and my grandpa's like whoa hey hey
he's like taking water like hey
nothing he could do like it was
happening it was just amazing the wire I
thought dude you all would like to boy
to always stuck to each other before
that was [ __ ] fun they were [ __ ]
yeah inside yeah well one was inside the
other but their two dudes and like they
were like yelping because they got stuck
they were like walking around like this
they're just a well we have to grow dogs
and they [ __ ] each other all the time
all the [ __ ] time dude I don't know
why it's like they hump each other well
isn't it a dominant thing yeah it's like
I don't know I noticed that it's like um
it's a way to relieve stress like if
they're [ __ ] biggest time by yourself
or whatever yeah but are they both me
yeah but if they're irritated or
whatever they just start [ __ ] each
other about dominance right cuz Mike cat
does that to my other cat too were like
one of the cat well my cat will be
Franklin will be asleep the gray cat and
then the yellow cat like comes in the
room starts meowing for no [ __ ]
reason and we're all kind of pissed
about it and then Franklin jumps off of
the couch from a deep sleep jobs on this
fools back and then bites the back of
his neck and my blonde starts humping is
like in a way is back yeah it's weird we
have a boy cat in a girl cat two boys
two boys and one is yellows [ __ ] for
sure copies everything the guy does
you're Franklin's [ __ ] too though I
think we all Franklin's [ __ ] I think
it's Franklin's house and [ __ ] dude I
never thought that that she was real
until I had one how old are the cats
you're like ten and seven I think what's
the average age 27 you think is average
age 20 yeah we're looking it up like
it's like the potential of living 30
years or some [ __ ] I mean her cats like
20-something uh that's all 0:02 to 16
yeah he's close to 20 though in the wild
oh well that's very huge difference yeah
they just didn't want to be wrong at
that point it isn't uncommon for indoor
cats to live to at least 20 that's
pretty cool dude you know what and dog
can't slip so long cuz they don't give
up
yeah there's a stress-free they could
give up [ __ ] less about anybody dude
they're not being chased yeah they don't
have to hunt for food hurt hurt cat at
her mom's place is completely cool until
Tiger comes over because he just wants
to [ __ ] like I don't know what he
wants to do it Mike is just so curious
tackle pet yeah he just wants to go and
just grab her and just [ __ ] start
throwing it everywhere I'll hand it to
him I think all cats are female for some
reason they look so feminine like walk
all feminine [ __ ] to walk all like I
mean because I have one boy and a girl
and I could clearly tell I mean they're
obviously my cats but I could see the
difference between the boy and the girl
the girl is like way more like feminine
way more like the bone structure is even
thinner and like if she's way more like
wiggle ear and then the boys like more
sturdy but a boy cat - like a dog that's
just clumsy
that's true cuz he's big everyone thinks
Maddie's a boy yeah cuz she's thirty my
earliest memory
like probably one of my three earliest
memories I'm in Indiana I'm like must be
three years old I see my cat taboo in
front of me it's just a completely black
cat and I see this object that's moving
off of the cuff of the cat and I was
like oh no I have to help taboo and so I
reach for this object that's moving and
I yank it back and it was taboos tale
but I didn't know what the [ __ ] sale
was and I remember not knowing what a
tail wasn't just thinking it was like
hurting her in some way how cute you
remember I remember that yeah that's a
kid's thing and then she's like full-on
jumped and that's what I remember this
is the trauma from that and like yeah
[ __ ] me up from that cuz I felt so
terrible that well I thought the cat
like scratched your folks she didn't she
was really nice around kids she was
always cool but did they can't hate you
after that no she was cool man she got
over it quick yeah but it stayed with me
forever like one time I killed a snake
in my backyard when I was like 12 cuz I
thought it was maybe poisonous and
couldn't hurt by a dog so I like cut its
head off with a shovel and then I found
out later on from my sister who's a vet
she's like this is just a garter snake
it wasn't and I felt so bad since then
like I could I get very sad about dude
every time I kill a snake I was like
yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of my backyard I don't like it man
I feel terrible hate [ __ ] snakes you
know I'm a little traumatized with
snakes too because one time I was
walking so this kid named Randy had a
pool like in a neighborhood close to
mine so we would always go to his house
and swim so we would walk back and it
was there's this bright little shoelace
on the floor and I was like oh it was a
[ __ ] snake I grabbed it by stealth
and it came to love it and I chucked
that [ __ ] right in somebody's backyard
wild dude I [ __ ] me makes man
traumatize ever since then you you
didn't like snakes before that snake or
that snake was the one I said it I
already did it like it that wouldn't
really cemented in stone for me right
there
[ __ ] shoelace that came to me I
didn't like snakes until 5th grade when
they brought snakes to our school me out
of assembly and then I had a Python go
around my neck and all these guys are
nice and I like them I hate snakes I
think it's also a biblical thing too
because they're like you're good yeah
they feel really good like a person I
don't like snakes but I don't but I
don't want I feel bad it's my worst
memory of doing something I feel
terrible but I like how they move like
when you feel the muscle oh yeah I like
that
[ __ ] buff without any having arms or
anything that's really probably killed
like my 4 or 5 of those [ __ ]
I don't like fast moving snakes as soon
as they're like like a rattlesnake oh
when they move quick oh I want to step
on it like relax
[Music]